[Music]
thank you everyone for your time today
just a quick recap of our agenda we're
going to be starting talking off
talking about some of the challenges the
data science teams face
and how our studio products can help
tackle those challenges
and how those challenges then help drive
people to consider moving to the cloud
and so then we'll talk about some of the
different cloud options that are out
there hosted services
working with the vpc provider such as
azure aws
cloud marketplace offerings and doing
data science in your data lake
and then i'll hand off to kevin for to
do a deep dive
on some of the factors that you should
consider when you are considering
deploying
your software to a vpc then we'll wrap
up and have time for as many questions
as we can
and as sam said any questions we don't
get to today we'll have a follow-up
thread on our community site
to continue the discussion there
so we've talked to many data science
teams in
a large variety of organizations over
the years and what we've heard from many
of them
is that a lot of data science teams fail
to live up to their full promise
of what they're trying to achieve what
the what the organization is hoping
the value that the organization is
hoping to get from this team
and there's lots of reasons for that and
these reasons tend to group
uh based on our conversations with again
many data science teams tend to group
into a few different areas
perhaps teams have trouble creating
insights
perhaps they have trouble once they have
actually created those insights to
actually use those insights to impact
decision making in the organization
because ultimately
you know if you've got a better way to
do things or a better way to make a
decision it only
actually matters if that gets
implemented and that actually impacts
your organization
or sometimes uh teams have the greatest
challenges around actually maintaining
and
improving this value over time that they
get some insights they create decision
making
but then it fades maybe they find it
difficult to maintain
so there are many different reasons many
different uh
challenges that go into these different
areas and things that teams need to
overcome
today we're going to be focusing on this
third column
that silo teams lead to often redundant
work
make collaboration difficult they may
spend too much time maintaining tools or
too much time re-running analyses
because teams can't easily deploy
self-service applications or perhaps it
takes too much manual effort to deploy
and maintain these systems
and i'm focusing on these because these
are the items that are often addressed
by centralizing your data science
and or moving it to the cloud
so what we found is that customers who
have successfully scaled their data
science
team and the work that they do and
impacted their organization
tend to focus on three key attributes of
their data science environment
open source code oriented and
centralized
and again in this session we'll focus on
the centralized and cloud aspect
open source of course is a key part of
our studio's mission and we
find it critical because it eases
recruiting and retention and training
for new people and it's comprehensive
and interoperable
code oriented is a key part of our
studio's philosophy of data science
because code is flexible
it doesn't have blackbox constraints and
code by its nature is easy to iterate
and
reuse and extend and inspect but again
in this session we'll focus
on the centralized and cloud aspects
because
centralizing your data science helps
reduce unnecessary work for the data
science team
makes it easier to collaborate across
that team
providing a common way of deploying
self-service applications to your
stakeholders helps inform them helps
drive decision-making and impact that in
the organization and of course
if you're working with open source tools
like r and python
finding some consistent way to manage
all the data science packages and manage
the versions of that is critical
and often that's easiest if you
centralize that so that it's common
across
both your development and deployment
environments
now these three key aspects open source
code oriented and centralized are key
aspects of what we call
serious data science and we call this
serious data science because this
approach typically
enables a data scientist to tackle the
complex
difficult and at least initially often
ill-defined problems
that can really provide value and novel
insights in an organization
now the two leading languages in open
source data science are of course
r and python but on their own
r and python certainly provide the open
source and code oriented aspects
but they don't out of the box on their
own make it easy to centralize
your data science or deploy to the cloud
and that's where our studio's commercial
products come in
our products support the development and
deployment of data science with both r
and python and we have a modular
platform called rstudio team that helps
you centralize your data science in an
enterprise friendly way providing
security and scalability etc
and so let's just talk about that
briefly um
now what's what does the data science
team actually need to do
well there's two things that they
typically need to do in part of their
work
they need to create insights and then
they need to find a way of sharing those
insights to impact decision making in
the organization
and so typically when they create in
science insights they're using some sort
of data science workbench
some way where they can use their ide of
choice whether it's jupiter notebooks or
rcr studio ide
or vs code you know all in a single
location use those different
development environments to create
various data products
using r and python these these typically
are tailored applications or reports or
apis
we call these tailored because they're
not off the shelf they're not block
black box but they're focused on the
problem at hand focused on providing the
exact
information that a decision maker needs
in their day-to-day work
and that's one of the big advantages of
course of a code-oriented approach you
don't have any arbitrary limitations you
can focus on what
your stakeholders need and of course
once they create these interactive
applications or reports or apis they
need a way of
publishing them a way of sharing them
and so typically they can publish these
to a deployment portal
and once this is available in a
deployment portal the data science team
can now
share these insights to impact decision
making
and this typically takes the form of an
interactive web application
say a shiny application that can be
shared with a decision maker
or an automated email report that can be
sent to the decision maker with
the analysis right within it so they
have that data within their
inbox or perhaps they create apis
that can be integrated into other
systems for automated decision making
and it's critical for both these areas
for both the development side and the
deployment side
that you have a way of managing your
open source packages because this eases
maintenance and reproducibility
and this course is where our products
come in our studio server pro provides
that centralized
data science workbench with a variety of
different development environments
rstudio connect provides that deployment
portal
where you can share your applications
and apis with your decision makers and
other systems
and these may take the form of shiny our
markdown plumber apis
also a number of different python um
frameworks that we pro
that we support things like streamlet
and bokeh
and it's critical for both of these that
you have a way of managing packages and
that's where our studio package manager
comes in
and it's these three products are studio
server pro connect and package manager
that make up our rstudio team bundle
and of course it's critical that this
all integrates with
standard systems in your organization
kevin will be talking a lot more about a
few of these especially kubernetes
moving forward
but the critical idea here is there's a
lot of benefits to
centralizing your data science and many
many of our customers do exactly this
you know on-prem and so the question is
what then drives people
to want to go to the cloud there are
several different reasons
um often a key reason
is simply simplifying and reducing the
startup cost for a new data science team
that when someone when an organization
is spinning up a new team
cloud is often a way to really get that
team and get the resources that team
needs going quickly perhaps they want to
make collaboration or
instructions say workshops or classes
between organizations or groups easier
cloud's a great way of doing that
perhaps they want to mitigate the high
cost of maintaining their own computing
infrastructure
this was one of the you know primary
drivers originally for
organizations to move to the cloud and
is still you know a major
factor closely aligned to that is
scaling to meet variable demand
that if your the demand for your
computations for your data science
computations is highly variable you
don't want to keep a bunch of expensive
computing infrastructure
um sitting around idle instead you want
to push that responsibility out to the
cloud provider to maintain that for you
and finally if your data is already in
the cloud
then you want to reduce time and costs
in moving the data
to your analysis and rather than pulling
it down locally to do data science it's
often
much more efficient and much less
expensive to do that data science
up on the cloud directly right into your
data lake
so let's talk about a few of these
different options again one of the most
common options
is doing a hosted
service where a vendor provides software
as a service we talk about a couple of
things our studio does there
the other very common way of doing this
is deploying to a virtual
private cloud provider such as azure or
aws
and i'll be touching on that lightly
here but kevin will be covering that in
a lot more detail in the next section
third and closely aligned is cloud
marketplace offerings again that's
very similar in some ways to deploying
to a vpc you're running on the cloud
provider's hardware
but here typically it's easier to start
up and it's it's done on an hourly basis
and finally data science in a data lake
such as qball or databricks
so hosted software service offerings
some of the things that really make
these offerings great are there easy to
quickly start up
and they streamline collaboration if the
members of your team can simply go in
put a credit card in and sign up for a
few dollars a month
to access some capabilities that's an
easy way
to scale up very quickly now sometimes
software service may have limited
functionality compared to on-prem
um so you might not have the full
options that you would have if you
were to install locally and sometimes
again depending on the service
integration with your data internal
systems could be more challenging or
perhaps not even possible
so a couple of offerings that our studio
has
in this arena we have rstudio cloud
which is a hosted version of the rstudio
server pro
with the rstudio ide makes it easy for
anybody to do
or share or teach or learn data science
using just your web browser
so the initial focus right now for our
skill cloud is primary
primarily for platfor as a platform for
instructor-led
education so if you were doing a
workshop
in your commercial organization or if
you were teaching a class on data
science or statistics at the university
level
our studio cloud is a great solution for
that and we have many organizations
using it for that
already another great uh
focus for our studio cloud right now is
enabling academic research
by sharing among different groups this
is a handy way of doing that
and there's a lot more um that will be
rolling out in our studio cloud over the
next
several months so some of the great
benefits of our studio cloud again
nothing to install locally all you need
is a browser you can share projects that
you create there with your team or a
class or workshop
and again nothing to configure no
hardware installation or anything like
that
just a month-to-month purchase and
there's
various plans available for our studio
cloud including
uh free to get started
shiny apps io is another hosted service
our studio provides this is a way of
securely and scalably
sharing your hosted your shiny
applications on a hosted service
and so if you have any application that
you want to share with the world or with
a much smaller group um you can do that
quickly on shinyapps.io
um again various plans available there
including
free to get started you can visit to
learn more
the second major area of uh
cloud second major way of going to the
cloud
is deploying to a virtual private cloud
provider like
aws or azure or google cloud platform
now some of the advantages of this is
that you can pay as you go
for the compute resources specifically
typically if you're deploying um to a
vpc you've purchased the license from
the vendor already
though not necessarily depends on the
offering um
another great advantage here you get the
full functionality of the on-premise
software because typically it is the
on-premise software
or a close variant of that that's
available on the
vpc so for example right now our studio
cloud doesn't yet have the ability to
uh provide our jupiter notebooks um in
that environment
that's you know one of the things we're
working on for the future but right now
if you were to deploy our studio server
pro to a vpc
you'd have the full functionality being
able to
utilize jupyter notebooks and jupyter
lab through the same capabilities that
you'd use the rstudio ide
vpcs also give you access to specialized
hardware
like gpus now on the con side it can be
difficult to maintain there's typically
more administration
overhead there's a complexity of things
like kubernetes that you
might need to consider and kevin is
going to be discussing all this
in a lot more detail in the next section
the other challenge around vpcs is that
the cost can be high
and variable that you need to really
manage the compute costs closely to make
sure the software is only available when
it's needed
otherwise it can keep running in the
background and rack up your
compute charges
third and again closely related is cloud
marketplace offerings going
instead of installing on your own on a
vpc
you go to the aws or azure or gcp cloud
marketplaces
to spin up software from a vendor our
studio has
offerings on all those marketplaces
it's very handy in a lot of ways because
it's easy to get started quickly
makes it great for proof of concepts
you're paying as you go
typically for both compute and software
licenses
on an hourly basis again very
inexpensive to get started
and again access to the specialized
hardware
but like deploying to a vpc you need to
make sure you carefully manage the
software to make sure it's only when
running when you need it otherwise you
could run into excessive hourly charges
which means often not always but often
this is best for short-term projects
especially if you're collaborating
between organizations because that's a
great way to provide access
outside your organization
and then finally data science in your
data lake great example of a data lake
is someone like qball a partner
for our studio qball provides
a data lake with our studio server pro
capabilities built into it
and some of the you know advantages here
is you can minimize the overhead by
running your computations
close to the data um avoiding the cost
of moving the data
from you know one cloud to another or
down
locally it also makes it easy to
incorporate data science directly into
your data pipeline
now on the con side running your data
signs in your data lake can add some
technical complexity can make it a
little bit more difficult to do what you
want to do or at least a little bit more
complicated
and again you might run into some
functionality limitations here
that could be challenging depending on
what the data lake provider
and the data science provider have done
and how they're working together
um technically
so to sum up this section um ultimately
it really depends on what your primary
goal is um
and based on your primary goal you could
different
ways of going to the cloud your primary
goal is to really minimize cost and
maintenance and startup time
then using a hosted service is often a
great
way to start there especially if you
have a small team or really just an
individual data scientist
if you want the full flexibility of an
on-prem solution
all the bells and whistles all the
capabilities but without maintaining
your own hardware
but still having the flexibility to
scale then deploying to a vpc
provider is often the best way to go
kevin will be talking more about that
next
if you're doing something that's much
more short term perhaps just a proof of
concept you don't want to commit to a
long time period
offerings on a cloud marketplace by the
hour are often a great way to do that
and again if your biggest concern is
your data is already in the cloud and
you want to minimize
the overhead of moving that data
someplace else to analyze it
then often data science in your data
lake is going to be the best approach
so with that i'll hand you off to kevin
thank you lou for that really good
introduction um
really appreciate that uh presentation
so i want to talk about
uh more along the lines of why
why you might want to move to cloud and
what are some of the key considerations
that people have
when they move to cloud and so this is a
big decision for a lot of organizations
to either switch from their on-premise
history or or maybe just expanding their
their cloud footprint for the data
science teams
um so next slide
there we go
so typically when we meet with clients
and we're discussing
cloud infrastructure for uh various
different data science applications and
primarily a lot of time we're speaking
about our studio team installations
and configurations uh we're considering
a lot of different things and the key
kind of facts that come up the key uh
recurring themes that we see coming up
are you know first of all assessing the
needs of the team you know how big is
their team how much did in power do they
need
and do they really need the cloud they
need to utilize the clouds
immense scale and do they see a lot of
potential future growth or unforeseen
growth in the future so do they need to
be able to scale their
their resources over time in an
unpredictable manner
and this is where cloud is really
powerful
and it's quite easy or relatively easy
to
configure your environments to scale
over time
if you understand where your team is
going and what your needs are going to
be
another key thing is you know how am i
going to control the cost so
with infinite scale comes infinitely
scaling bills
so uh this is a big concern as as lou
alluded to it's a pay-as-you-go model
but unfortunately that means if you use
lots and lots of resources you're going
to get charged from lots of resources so
uh controlling costs is a very key
consideration it's a
much more straightforward to control
those costs when you when you are the
ones maintaining the physical
infrastructure because you've got a very
defined view of what it can be
um but when you're dealing with
virtually unlimited resources
um your bills can get out of hand quite
quickly so there's
different ways that you can mitigate
against that and we'll we'll talk a
little bit more about that
another key consideration we work with a
lot of clients in
more regulated industries whether
they're working in
industries with uh proprietary
information or maybe they're working in
industries where
they handle a lot of very sensitive data
around customers
so pii that you know is maybe needs to
be treated with a high degree of
sensitivity
and this is a this is a
consideration a key consideration that
maybe slows up the adoption of cloud
over time and so typically these
industries are
are lagging behind the more uh versatile
or the more uh
the more the the tech industries that
are maybe able to move a little quicker
and these don't have these uh
regulations that they need to consider
and so
they often ask you know can i how can i
secure my cloud and
the answer really is as secure as you
want to make it
and we can dive a little bit more deep
into that in a few minutes
uh another key consideration is of
course you're handing over the keys of
your infrastructure to a cloud provider
and
um you know if you go back as far as the
early naughties and the tech boom and
there was plenty of websites that were
being hosted by young entrepreneurs in
in their in their uh home offices or
their bedrooms little computers that put
under desks and they were hosting
websites that way but
um with the immense scale of these uh
these cloud infrastructure companies and
they're much more sophisticated
organizations and
while you're handing over the keys to
them and they're managing the physical
security of your infrastructure and
they're they're able to benefit from
that massive scale to really secure
their infrastructure in a way that
is quite difficult to do and so we can
uh talk a bit more about that
and then the last one and this kind of
ties back to our first point
with uh with regards to scale and that
is
how do i adapt to change and how easy is
it to do that
you know if if i architect a solution
and i build it and
all of a sudden i see a huge uptick in
usage and
how can i make sure that uh we can scale
our environment for our teams in an
efficient manner so that we don't see
any downtime or we don't have very
lengthy delays between
uh making more resources available and
again this is somewhere where cloud can
really excel if you
if you know what you're doing so yeah
thank you you can go to the next slide
loop
so when we initially engage with our our
clients one of the
uh first things we we like to talk to
them about
um is we carry out a series of
interviews with
their key users and the business users
to try and get a better understanding
across all the different products that
they're trying to embed in their teams
so
uh as lou mentioned our studio pro for
the data scientists people who are doing
the development work
uh r studio connect you know the
platform for sharing that information
with
the users and pac-man for uh
sharing the sorry for controlling the
managing the
it kind of security and package
management
so i i put together this small matrix
just to kind of
give it
some of those considerations that we'd
like to take into account so
we're looking to understand you know
let's say if we take for example
our studio pro how big is their team how
many
what's the make up the team the context
of the team is there a lot of data
scientists people running a lot of
simulations
how variable are their workloads what's
the kind of size of data they're dealing
with are they dealing with
very small data you know the order of
megabytes are they're really a big data
shop who are dealing with petabytes or
terabytes of data
and also the size of the team definitely
matters right if you've got a very small
team if you've got a team of five people
um you know you could probably handle
your workloads in a much more simple
architecture but as you scale up your
team or your scale up the size of your
data you might want to consider more
complex approaches and that's
where lou is alluding to earlier with
the clustered approach with
kubernetes and so i've kind of broken it
up here and you can think about and this
is
definitely a rule of thumb and you know
your mileage may vary as they say and
this all comes out as a result of a
series of interviews with your team and
understanding your needs
um but smaller teams more simple teams
will benefit from a simpler approach and
those are the ones in the yellow zone so
if you're dealing with
relatively small teams with relatively
small amounts of data
you could probably get away with a more
basic or simple approach
again taking into consideration how
variant is the workloads in those teams
you know are you seeing a large
differentiation and
making architectures works for those as
well and the same with the red zone you
know if you're dealing with very large
sets of data
or very large teams you're definitely
going to want to consider a more complex
approach because uh
it's just harder to predict what your
team's going to be able to do so you're
maybe going to want to
work with a more scalable solution
something that can flex with the needs
of your team over time
and then if you're sitting in that
orange area again you're going to have
to think a little harder about
what kind of workloads you're running
how predictable are they
and you know you might be sitting
somewhere in between the
more simple approaches or the more
complex approaches depending on
the type of work that your team does um
yes uh you can go to the next slide loop
so there are a number of different
solutions that you can uh implement in
the cloud to
to uh implement your architecture from
the very simple and to the more complex
as a lieu and alluded to there there is
something like a quick start image from
most
cloud providers in in aws and i've
provided some aws analogous
examples throughout this presentation
in aws we have something called an
amazon machine image and this is just a
pre-configured image where you can
quickly spin up the machine and test out
test it and so this is better for
maybe short-term projects or where we
typically recommend this be used is
in cases where people really just want
to kind of play around with our studio
and see is it
worth investing their time into and so
they can quickly launch it and
test it out and get it up and running
without too much work and so this is a
good for a prototyping phase or just
kind of seeing what rstudio is all about
if you're maybe new to that or you're
maybe new to cloud
and seeing does it work well with your
different systems but it comes at a bit
of a premium and so as lou was saying
you'd probably want to make sure you
don't leave it on all the time you're
going to get charged by the hour for
your machine and the license fees
and really if you're going to go ahead
and deploy our studio in a
truly productionized manner in a serious
enterprise situation
you're going to want to consider one of
the other options
and so the simplest approach you can
take is a virtual machine
uh deployed on a vpc
in aws they have something called the
elastic complete cloud and that's their
virtual machine
deployment and so ec2 instances as
they're called
you can go ahead and pick all the ram
and cpu requirements that you need
picture right or west that can be a very
important consideration for some teams
if you need a
red hat linux environment or do you need
a or can you are you okay with an open
source environment like ubuntu
uh you want to consider then do you want
to be highly available or not
and if you need double redundancy this
is this is something we often recommend
that people are working in the cloud
is our studio has a built-in load
balancer that will distribute traffic
evenly across the different machines if
you've got multiple machines running
but you can implement some double
redundancy which is super important for
a lot of teams to make sure that
if the master node goes down you don't
lose access to your environment
and so we use load balancers in the
cloud and every every
major cloud provider has some version of
this
and this ultimately allows for us to
scale our resources
vertically um so we can or you know you
can actually scale it out horizontally
as well but
typically if you're doing that we
recommend the next approach
which is kubernetes so just for those
who may be uninitiated
you know scaling vertically would be
just increasing the the amount of ram or
cpu that your machine has
versus skating horizontally is simply
adding more of the same machine
um but if you're going to go with that
approach we recommend going with a
cluster approach so if you've got a
larger team and you've got variable
workloads
uh you might want to consider using
something like kubernetes and so again
every
cloud provider has their own version of
this on amazon they've got a managed
service called amazon eks or amazon
elastic kubernetes service
and this is really great for enterprises
that have variable workloads and also if
you want to
version control your your environment
you can use docker to
containerize your solutions your
environment and
scale this infinitely to your team's
needs so if your team grows
you just configure your cluster to grow
with your team
and again utilize those load balancers
the final one here that i want to point
out and that's an inbuilt feature that's
come out in our studio in the last
couple of years that uh
some people may be aware of and that's a
server pro launcher and this
integrates well with kubernetes so uh
what this allows you to do is
win your regular environment so maybe
you've got pretty low
uh compute needs on an everyday basis
within your team
um so maybe you don't need an eks
environment maybe you're okay with an
ec2 instance but
every once in a while you want the
ability to scale up your jobs to a much
larger
scale so that's where job launcher can
be really effective
and allowing power users to run those
heavy workloads without bringing to a
halt
to the base instances so if you've got a
team of 10 data scientists they're all
working
and they're using their estimates and
somebody wants to run a really heavy
model training or simulation they can
utilize this job launcher and
not take down or tank the entire ec2
instance for everybody else and so it
isolates that workload
from everybody else in the team
you can go to the next slide
so uh pay as you go uh only pay for what
you use this is
uh one of the great benefits of
cloud but only if you do it right uh
you can definitely get this wrong and
end up with a big unexpected bill
so some of the common mistakes that
people see
is you over position your resource and
this comes down to poor planning so
you over over uh estimate your needs and
you
essentially just by some percentage
amount um
overspend or have a have machines set up
an architecture setup that is maybe just
a little bit too much for what you
actually needed
and you can scale that down and if
you're monitoring that well
another one is poor limit planning so
you know most cloud providers will allow
you to set limits on your spend or
limits on uh
how big you want your clusters to get or
limits on what machines are different
people are allowed to use and stuff like
that and so
if you're not planning that out or if
you're not utilizing it at all um like
you say with clusters the cluster will
grow to as big of the needs as the team
use so if you've got a team of data
scientists and uh you don't have any
limits set and
they get carried away with themselves
you could end up with a very large bill
at the end of the month
and the last one is uh lu alluded to is
shutting down those unused resources
um so
what we see in a lot of teams is uh they
use you know elastic map producer to use
clusters
and the analysts will turn on their
clusters and do their analysis but
they'll forget to
shut it off so uh if they're not using
scalable infrastructure and they're
they're setting up a lot of a lot of
expensive machines and they leave it
running overnight you know that can be a
pretty hefty build in the morning um for
somebody if they forgot to turn things
off so
you can you can definitely mitigate
against these uh problems so
you can be very thoughtful and uh plan
about planning your architecture and
this is something where we really
work a lot with our clients on and
making sure that we spend a lot of time
in the planning phase when we're not
rushing into implementing the solutions
we really want to make sure
that the solution that we're
architecting for them is right for them
now and right for them six months from
now so it's the right mix of
balancing for what they need today but
also take into consideration what are
they going to need in the future
make sure you're utilizing those budgets
and monitoring and alerts
be very clever about that and utilize
that to the max because that's going to
help prevent any unexpected
builds or any surprises categorize your
spends make sure that you know if you
are overspending you're able to
easily pinpoint where in your system
you're you're over spending so you can
you know isolate that offending uh
instance or or cluster and make
mitigating actions to that
and of course you need to regularly
reassess so you know you can plan as
much as you want but your team's needs
are going to change over time
maybe your team grows or maybe your team
is downsizing a little bit and you can
you know you can go with a smaller
instant size but you need to regularly
come back to that
you can go to the next slide
the next key question is how secure is
the cloud and
like i said earlier it can really be as
secure as you want to be so
a lot of people will think oh well if i
have my physical infrastructure in-house
on the premise
that's the most secure i can be but i
mean that's not always the case because
you've got to pay for the security
within your own premise you've got to
pay for security guards if you're really
concerned about people coming in and
doing harm to your infrastructure
uh you got to maintain that
infrastructure
and you're going to maintain all the
firewalls and security around that
if you work with the cloud um amazon and
their shared responsibility model
are different cloud providers they will
maintain the security and
uh integrity of those physical machines
and they provide all of the software
that you need that
you could possibly need to configure the
security so really
it can be as secure as you want it to be
and that is a real caveat because you
need to make sure that you're
configuring your your
your your configuring your solutions to
be as secure as your requirements might
be
so if you have a very high security need
you need to scale up your investment in
your
architecture appropriately
and in different cloud providers and i'm
going to use aws again as an example
you've got
different resources so you can have a
vpc that's completely private
which subnets are completely private or
or maybe completely public or maybe a
mix of the two
and you can have different instances in
each environment that can speak to each
other across using
or what are known as an amazon an amazon
resource name but
again in every cloud provider you've got
this ability to allow services to talk
to each other without having
humans have access to those services so
this is really powerful if you want to
utilize like serverless technology
maybe have an entry point that a human
can interact with but the underlying
hardware or data or
infrastructure they can't access it's
only the actual services on aws that
they do have access
that can do that um so if you go to the
next slide we can see an example of that
and this is just an example where you've
got two vpcs you know they're private
subnets inside of them ordinarily these
two instances
shouldn't be able to interact with each
other but again amazon provides the
software
you can use this vpc peering connection
and make sure that these instances are
now able to communicate with each other
so a malicious actor could not
communicate with these private subnets
or the private instances
but you can actually configure these
services to be able to talk to each
other and that can be really powerful
and
important for a lot of use cases and
making sure that your
different systems across your
organization are able to talk to each
other without compromising security
you can go to the next slide
again just to point out this is an
example here of the
aws shared responsibility model and just
really to point out that
it's up to your organization to
configure
a secure environment so that's your
portion of the shared responsibility
model
aws will provide and maintain the
software and hardware
needed to to uh do all that but
you need you need to take responsibility
for making sure that
your privacy and security is meeting
your requirements
so if you're from a rape a highly
regulated industry you need to consider
that
there's also some governed cloud options
um that if you're working in a
government agency
most cloud providers have an option
that's exclusive to the government
agencies
and that could be very important as well
you can go to the next slide loop
again i want to keep on the track of
this shared responsibility model and
we're talking about the stability of
environments so
if i don't have access or i don't have i
don't control my physical infrastructure
how can i ensure that it's going to be
safe that everything's going to be
safeguarded and what happens if there is
a disaster
and am i going to lose all my data i'm
going to lose all my services and again
uh you really can take advantage of the
scale of the cloud in this
in this sense so yes if you were to
architect your
solutions poorly and that's you know
that's your portion of the shared
responsibility model
you can expose yourself to instability
within the
cloud infrastructure so you want to make
sure when you're architecting your
solutions that you're taking advantage
of some of the features that
cloud providers have so in the case of
aws
uh they've got many regions around the
world uh dozens of them and they're
constantly adding these regions
and uh they also then have within those
regions many different availability
zones these are geographically distinct
areas within those geographically
distinct areas and finally within those
they have data centers and
these are where your actual machines
live
so if you want to make sure that you
don't uh you aren't
hit by a disaster and you know you lose
all your data you lose
all of your compute or you lose access
to your systems
you can act tech solutions that mitigate
fur dash
and in that way you know the cloud can
be way more scalable
and way more secure and stable than any
on-premise solution could ever be um if
you take advantage of this cloud and
that means
you just got to architect it carefully
and if you go to the next slide we can
have a look here and you can see yeah we
can go and we can
make sure if we if we need if we have a
global team and we want this highly
available environment we want to make
sure that we've got
our our systems mirrored across many
different regions
so that means if something happens in
the oregon region
and one of the data centers
experiences a big outage which can
happen um
it's okay because we've got a mirrored
uh environment inside of north virginia
and so our analysts our data scientists
can continue to do their work
you also want to make sure you're
setting up disaster recovery effectively
uh so that you know if you if you do uh
have one region still make sure you're
backing up your data in separate areas
um especially if you've got mission
critical information in your
infrastructure
so just making it you know just making
that point that you know data centers
can
fare i can't fail um machines can
fail this is the reality uh cloud
providers take advantage of that scale
and the expertise they have in house to
mitigate
against that and reduce that down as
much as they can but it's on you to make
sure
that you architect solutions that also
prevents that as much as possible
okay you can go to next slide blue
and yeah there's the just closing
remarks then on um
architecting on cloud and the different
solutions just tying back to
again that idea of of scale and
uh you can plan as well as you want and
you can build your team
out or you can plan your architecture as
well as well as you want around your
current needs and
maybe even project your needs a little
bit into the future but
oftentimes what we see is uh people want
to be very conservative they're like i
don't know how
this is going to get adopted and lo and
behold because it's such great software
um especially our studio team connect
is something that sees a great a lot of
adoption once it starts getting
circulated within organizations
uh suddenly your demand for those
services will spike
and so you want to be able to respond to
that effectively now if you're using
on-premise servers you're using physical
infrastructure in your house
that means you have got to go and you
got to call up your your hardware
provider and order new machines and
have them shipped to your site and then
have your it team install them and
configure them and
install the software and it's a it's a
time lag so you're adding weeks onto
your process
with cloud if you're clever and you've
automated your deployments in an
effective way which you can do
with uh stuff like uh cloud formation
it means that yeah i can i can scale up
uh
my my architecture as quickly as i want
to get it scaled up and take advantage
of that infinite scale in the team
so if you're planning on a lot of scale
um you know consider that maybe you need
to
use a clustered approach if you if you
think your team's really going to grow
or just uh just be aware of the
different uh
the different uh growth that your team
might experience and
take advantage of the monitoring that uh
different cloud providers have to
monitor that usage you know
in aws you have cloud watch you can
really monitor that uh monitor that
and uh our studio professional has
inbuilt
monitoring so you can build custom
monitoring solutions but keep a close
eye on on usage patterns
and understand when you need to scale it
up and then if you've got a
clever architect or uh cloud cloud
engineer
you can easily scale up your your
solutions which
without that uh time lag of uh
ordering and procuring that physical
infrastructure
and i think that's the last slide if you
go to the next one
just to highlight that um as i mentioned
throughout uh prakogi are a full service
partner with our studio
what that means for us is it means we're
we're licensed to resell
the different r studio products but we
also do training and implementation and
configuration of our studio team
environment so
we work with clients to architecture
solutions and we have people then who
are
qualified and trained to go in and
install and configure those solutions
and maintain
those solutions over a long period of
time as
teams learn to control their own
environments
and that is the end of the presentation
great thanks kevin um and just a quick
word on
our studio i'm sure you know who our
studio is if you're listening to this
webinar
but you might know us best through open
source work things like
creating and maintaining the tidy verse
set of packages to make r
easier to use and easier to learn tiny
applications for creating web-based
applications from our are marked down
to deliver essentially our notebooks to
deliver reproducible interactive r based
reports and presentations and documents
as well as our ide and certainly
creating and supporting this open source
software is
and will continue to be our studio's
core mission
in fact we announced earlier this year
that we've reorganized ourselves as a
public benefit corporation
which means now our open source mission
our commitment to this is codified into
our business charter and
all our decisions as an organization
must balance
the interests of all our stakeholders
including our community our customers
and our employees
but an important point is the pro
products that i was talking about at the
beginning of the session
our studio team really fund our open
source mission
so that means by buying our products not
only do you get the tools you need to
help
scale out your open source data science
investments but you're also helping
support
the open source data science community
and if you haven't seen it i strongly
encourage you to check out the
keynote from jj our ceo and founder um
recorded at the last our studio conf
where he talks about our announcement
around being a public benefit
corporation
and really the philosophy of who our
studio is and where we're going
and of course in addition to our open
source software being used by
millions of people every week we have
thousands of active
uh commercial software customers
including 59 to the fortune 100
and we're trusted by many of the world's
leading brands
and so with that um you know kevin and
i'd be happy to answer as many questions
as we can
in the time remaining
wonderful thank you so much lou and
kevin that was really informative
it looks like we have enough time
for me for two maybe three questions so
i'll go ahead and just dive right in um
i'll start off with the first one i
think this is going to be
for uh looks like it'll be for kevin
here and how can you figure out the
compute power that you or your team
needs
if you have not done it before if you're
just getting started
that's a really good question and uh
there right there is guidance
on our studio and we actually have a
recorded webinar
uh that i think might be shared out as
well of uh samantha
that goes deeper into uh the compute
power uh configuration so
we did a recorded webinar on
architecting your solutions for the
cloud
uh where we deep dive into how you can
configure that
um but there is guidance on the r studio
documentation on the minimum
requirements but i'm going to go ahead
and assume that
maybe the minimum requirements aren't
suitable for you and so
yeah if you actually want to get started
you're just interested in in learning
how you can do this how you can kind of
get a good estimate
um we actually have a a a free
tool that you can go on to uh it's you
can sign up on
course.procogia.com and uh on there
there's an akuna auto architecture tool
and this allows you to just go in and
fill out a form it's got some basic
questions
and it'll spit out then at the end when
you submit your form
a suggested architecture so what machine
sizes it recommends based off the input
that you give
and uh it's in bed of farm at the moment
my engineers would want me to caveat
with that
and so we'll give you a rough estimate
definitely don't
implement straight away but you know
take that as a good first stab and then
optimize from there
but that could be a really good starting
point is you know fill out that
questionnaire
generate an architecture from that uh
you know with different recommended
machine sizes and types and
architectural diagrams that go along
with that and it even
comes with some terraform scripts that
can help you quick start on aws if
you're if you're interested in aws as a
platform
um but other than that it's a it's
really discussion it's uh
uh you gotta consider how much ram
you're gonna need
um you know if if we're to get into the
formula
part of it uh you know if you've got a
lot of um
data that you're processing and you're
doing a lot of uh linear algebra
and then ram requirements are going to
be very important uh
cpus are going to be very important if
you've got a lot of concurrent users
and so there's lots of considerations
that go into uh what are the different
specs that you might need inside of your
machine
excellent thank you kevin i think that's
really helpful um and then
one more question um so in the context
of sharing
code etc and even the data um what are
some best practices for working with us
government requirements
um most of uh in this question they say
all of our projects are physically
siloed even in our own vpc
and do not share space so kevin or lou
what would be some best practices you
might recommend here
i i can actually go uh give a brief
description because uh
we we have been working with a client
similar to that recently
um and yeah i i feel the pain uh there
is a lot of
restrictions on the environments and so
thankfully these organizations are are
kind of becoming more
open to the cloud which makes things
easier um
and it really just comes down to i think
if you're working with government data
most cloud providers as i mentioned have
a government cloud option where the
servers are
completely isolated from the public
infrastructure so only government
agencies have access to this
so um you might want to utilize one of
those if you're moving to the cloud
and as far as like sharing data
information um we've actually been
helping a client
uh come up with a virtual clean room
scenario so
as you mentioned you know how can you
keep how can you isolate data
and code and stuff like that from from
people because you don't want everybody
have access to that data you don't have
every access to your proprietary code
and there's a lot of privacy concerns
there
and so you can utilize something like
kubernetes
to containerize your solutions and
within those containerized solutions
configure all the privacy requirements
that you need
and uh if you can imagine like a push
button exercise where somebody presses a
button and it automatically launches
a container that has all of the access
pre-configured
and associated with their profile and so
that's what we call a virtual clean room
so it essentially means that
everybody who's working off this
environment uh is completely
you know they're getting like a fresh
clean install uh completely unperturbed
by anybody else's
sessions and so it's completely
independent of everybody else and
it's only been used by them and it only
has access to the data that their
profile should allow them to have access
to so that's
that's one way we're looking at helping
clients at the moment and one of the
best practices
yeah that i could see right now are
future best practices it's a
really exciting project